[Music]
this is you welcome with me [ __ ]
Marcela argüello my guests today are Ida
Rodriguez who you can catch on episode 3
of Netflix as they ready and
kimberly-clark
who has been seen on Lopez Tonight and
Last Comic Standing thank you ladies for
being here thanks for how are you doing
I'm doing great I'm happy to be here
thank you
anything new popping up in your life
anything going on you know I'm just
trying to work through comedy after you
release a special oh yeah yeah how's
that it's interesting because they don't
want to hear the same jokes but they
want to hear the same jokes right right
so you get caught in how do you play
that right they also want the same like
quality ready jokes yeah that's the
other difficulty is like churning out
the new [ __ ] yeah writing new material
yeah and you Kimberly
you're like a little Miss you're always
in hiding it's like a sieve yeah someone
introduced me as elusive I was like oh
am I the Shaddai of kind of like it -
yeah you should like it are you shocked
you're doing this actually thank you I
appreciate that's respect right there
thank you yeah cuz I had somebody be
like who was it raised she was like we
made sure to be a late night house like
it'll [ __ ] no [ __ ] is on more [ __ ] I'm
gonna propriate black culture girl on
your way to be in the TV show
[Music]
so I wanted to talk about corporate gigs
do you do them do you hate them what's
the word what's the good word on
corporate gigs I've done a corporate gig
I feel like a corporate gig incorporated
one um I actually feel like college gigs
are getting like corporate gigs if not
worse yeah they're actually worse but I
feel like when I was doing colleges a
lot I was getting to like the beginning
of how you know stringent they are about
what you say what you could talk about
can't talk about and I remember going to
a college and they were telling me about
this comic that was there before and how
they were joking about something that
happened on campus and made him like
that and so I guess they were giving me
the morning shot you know they don't you
do that
so which have you ever had problems with
that because I'm not relatively clean
yeah this isn't my issue but it's also
not fun even when you're relatively
right because you're still under that
pressure like I could say anything right
you know bring up a topic and it's like
lights out yeah you know I have a
condition if you book me you have to
book me so that's me that's me that dude
what I [ __ ] what am i when they try
to get me to do colleges that are pg-13
I'm like no I don't need it first of all
what does that mean anymore
oh yeah that's open to interpretation of
them like if they want me they have to
have me
yeah they got to book me as I am or not
and that's fine I I did this gig for a
company that's a very popular company
and it was really I felt like I was in
The Stepford Wives like this woman's
event and all the women were like I love
people and I Stepford wife ship for you
I mean I see things I hate people period
yes I love people I just want to connect
with everyone and I was like crazy like
I don't lie because it's not true yeah I
don't want to do you want to connect
notes McConnel like I don't you know I
mean like I sit there and I'm like get
out of here with this [ __ ] right
I try my I don't I don't like to feel
handcuffed and muzzled right now I refer
to that again so I don't want to do any
other jobs
I'm not that
desperate I rather go do post mates to
make my bill that should be not who I am
for a check yeah so that's where I am
now and people get mad at me because
they're they hit you with the who do you
think you are and I'm like oh
exactly what that's the problem for them
because I think it's also the history of
like people doing corporate gifts I mean
cuz comedy has been strictly straight
white meal and and they they've jumped
to the chance they see of money offer
and they're like yeah I can be clean and
then they maybe are but maybe they
struggle through it i mean i don't know
i'm not watching these corporate gangs
that they're up to but i assume that
they're you know adapting for the for
the income and some of the some comics
are great at corporate gigs but like if
it's not for you i don't understand why
people do it and the more famous you get
the more you can say right so yeah
everybody like they give them more
leeway yeah the money goes up and they
get more leeway yeah but you know it's a
bunch of repressed people like corporate
people that work in those structures
where they can't be themselves anyway
you can't masturbate accounting here
they want to hear you they want there
yeah yeah yeah i know a lot of clean
comics that make me want to jump off of
them you know am i making so much money
yeah but i mean like that's not a good
motivator
i mean that's the problem with a lot of
people you know when i was taking
meetings with agencies i like had a ball
wind up and at the first i sat down the
first thing i did was like i'm not
motivated by money so if you can't [ __ ]
with that then you can't [ __ ] with me at
all
I'm not motivated by money yeah yeah it
doesn't take you anywhere in comedy
great you know you can be the richest a
successful comedian in the game I know a
lot of people who have a lot of money
and nobody respects them right like look
at them and say did you watch that oh
that was terrible great when you think
about comedy and what motivates
comedians most of them just want to make
people happy you want to make people
laugh and they want to heal right and it
doesn't matter how you feel about the
comic and the content if you really look
at the intention of that person how many
people actually go on say on stage and
say you know what I'm gonna go [ __ ] all
black people I'm gonna catch it right
that that's just not them the reality of
house comedians the way they express
what they have to say may be problematic
to you because of usually it's
privileged that feels disrupted by that
right those of us that grew up
struggle are like oh that's an
expression of what I'm familiar with
yeah and it's also if you have different
types of people in your life when you
grew up watching like you know how to
adapt and accept different types of
voices cuz I always think about my dad
and that my dad is like just a classic
much he's more Latino and it has kind of
helped because he but he wasn't like
them he wasn't the worst machismo man
I've ever met in my whole life but like
when you're young you're just like this
sexist guy what's his deal and you get
old and you're like well ELISA is not
rape and [ __ ] know anything like
there's actual things that people are
actually doing that is terrible and it's
like to to what a police language is
what it complicates all the stand-up
[ __ ] the thing is for me is because of
where I grew up and how I grew up to
survive
how you gonna let somebody one person's
point of view disrupt the way exactly it
also strikes me as people who don't know
how to navigate what's happening within
themselves they don't know how to
navigate the problems that are happening
with the people in their lives because
I've had a situation with between
homegirls where one girl was trying to
be like you your boyfriend likes quittin
Tarantino and you and she tried to
lecture the boyfriend and I pull it to
the side and I was like [ __ ] your
boyfriend likes Quentin Tarantino like
why aren't you talking to him I am
talking it was like well then handle
that and deal with that before you come
out some other [ __ ] cuz like damn calm
down Quentin Tarantino gates Salma Hayek
naked with some snakes around her body
through the world is the god of all gods
hilarious some people yeah that's funny
so I wanted to ask you both of what it's
like as a woman who is black and brown
and how that experience has shifted over
the years as a comedian I guess people
say I'm not typical or whatever whatever
that mean what is typical I wasn't
raised rich but at the same time I
wasn't poor you know we weren't the
Cosby's but you know we're like right in
the middle we were like the Winslows
yeah yeah I grew up in an Italian
neighborhood in Syracuse New York
yikes but at the same time my dad was a
preacher and so you know our church was
on the south side of Syracuse which you
know if there's a South Side didn't know
you know everybody was black there so I
had both sides you know what I mean to
draw from you have such a unique and
fresh voice which is like such a
annoying thing to say which has been
difficult for me does which has been
difficult for me because I feel like
people will say oh I love you but then
they're like but where can I put you how
can I mark it right and so that's that's
always been like a struggle but I enjoy
what I do so much that it really doesn't
deter me or make me want to quit I've
been seeing people to have started way
after I have like rise and I'm like wow
you know but I must really love this
yeah I'm still doing it but I've also
seen people who started after me who
have quit because it was too hard and it
was a lot of work that's true and it's
so ridiculous that there's nowhere to
put you because you're [ __ ] and
you're so funny and you're so great
thank you
I feel the same way you know what's
funny though everybody who's great and
successful on that level all have the
same story that when they were on their
climb people were like we don't know
where to put you yeah because as usually
because that means you're unique and
you're not like everybody else and
you're not cookie cutter so they know
where to put those people because
everything's so formulaic they're like
oh I guarantee you they are gathering
all the black sketch women right exactly
trying to put together just another
black lady oh they're gonna call it the
ebony skit I promise you that they're
working on that you are cuz that's the
how this town works yeah I am ghetto I
come from the ghetto you know like and
I'll get people say Wow
you know when I thought you were get old
but you're really smart as if you can't
be bull right right and or like because
there's no spectrum you know there that
we don't we're not allowed the spectrum
like why people can be honey booboo all
the way to Grey's Anatomy we got a we
have to be one or the other in a box and
what about Grey's boo-boo you know what
I mean where she know that's right yeah
I don't have to be talking about how I
love Twinkies and you know like how I
Drive my draw my eyebrows on and my
grandmother hit me when I was chunk let
down whatever the I don't have to do
that you they lead you to believe that
that's the way to do it but I refuse and
I'm gonna I'm gonna always go deeper and
harder and make people uncomfortable cuz
that's what I feel my job in comedy sure
yeah and I'm never gonna let anybody
tell me that I need to be more what's
the word less aggressive yeah I'm never
gonna let anybody convince me when I saw
that daily called dumb ass video with
all the dum-dums everybody on the
spectrum talking about how comedy is
masculine and women are not funny oh
yeah yeah yeah you know all the best
reparo looking like Rain Man I'm not
gonna let anybody tell me I had to sit
next to that guy on a pathetic on just
[ __ ] on Annette the whole time and my
whole thing was like if you don't like
my net you don't think it's funny don't
watch it yeah yeah many you dumbass
white boys without a watching comedy
yeah I mean but that's also the point
isn't the point of all these streaming
services is like what are the numbers I
mean if you're watching and you're
talking about even if it's hate you're
creating discussion which creates more
numbers so like if you actually hate it
you would actually not talk about it at
all I wouldn't I mean I don't I don't
listen I don't listen to country music
but I'm going to George straights page
to say you should I don't care enough
but when it with regards to comedy I've
had salt and I talked about this I just
did this interview women are always
being Verity you watch when you start
doing comedy how many people walked up
to you and say hey let me
some notes Oh coach my gosh it is city
let me tell you something this is what
you should do you shouldn't be dressing
up as if you're pretty or Corey Holcomb
was the one that told me if you ever
have to host the Oscars you're gonna
have to wear a gown and be funny so you
should be able to do comedy in a bikini
and be funnier I'm so modest but that's
your personality but also you got a man
so actually not anymore she don't got a
man anymore but yeah I'm so modest but
um I mean - you got you a man so I
wanted to ask you ladies how do you deal
with internet trolls the incessant
harassment that we as people in public
deal with because I get internet trolls
oh my god you love it though I do love
it you feed off of it you've made a
business out of it your response
yeah it's really fun I enjoy I don't
have Charles really you don't have
trolls that's because I don't post so
that's true you don't pose go get
Kimberly Clark she needs trolls my
mother told me so yeah that's good wait
you need that yeah I'm not gonna do it
they're gonna be like oh they're gonna
start doing the tweet and they go blah
but did you see that I asked man I'll
take that ya know but my mother um she's
to say stuff like my most beautiful
daughter is Debra right and so my name
is Kim you and I have three sisters by
the way so well two sisters is three of
us in a brother anyway and then my dad
will be like Kimberly is beautiful she's
beautiful and then my mother be like
she's attractive oh she has nice teeth
nuts
oh man that's I love that I'm like I
want to be your mom's friend and my mom
my mom is evil okay me my your mom
that's subtle that's that sort of [ __ ]
that's that Keyser söze [ __ ] my mom King
Kong right right me my brothers and my
sister sitting there we having this
conversation I told my mom we all know
you love Chino more than the rest of us
she said where did you get that from
I said you say it
your actions daily and she said well
today I will say it with my mouth crying
yeah how old are you [ __ ] that was four
years ago we've got some questions to
answer if you want any questions
answered life love the pursuit of
happiness or anger whatever you need
submit them to you welcome questions at
gmail.com first question how do you feel
if a guy calls you high maintenance what
do you do and what do you respond with
correct yeah you know what's funny when
I was in my early twenties my brothers
pulled me up my own brothers pulled me
aside aware like you're too
high-maintenance I do I'm a dancer like
wow what do you mean I made it cuz I
didn't even really like understand the
concept that that young and like you
want a guy who doesn't drink doesn't
smoke is gonna treat you good that's not
out there I was like wait that does
simple thing but now it's like those
aren't the standards but like back then
those really that was all I wanted was
just like a guy who's a good guy the
clean-cut guy for Europe yes per my
perception at that time I was like
that's those are all the things I need
and they're like you're too
high-maintenance and I'm just like well
that doesn't make sense I didn't
understand and then like I've only
gotten like only higher maintenance and
that in that sense of like what I want
but I like and but I will [ __ ] anything
so I've been called high maintenance
even though I don't think I actually
have any standards but apparently I do
it's some amazing how you become high
maintenance because you just have
standards right so now I'm not a high
maintenance person I don't want anybody
to pay my bills or take care of me I
just want to be treated with respect and
dignity which is like but it's not a
concept you know it's high maintenance
to some people it's like all she
requires too much and it's like really
like uh are you serious yeah it's called
by that's the other thing I think for
every guy hide maintenance it's a
different concept I was gonna say what's
the definite what is your take
you know maybe that's the response when
someone what is your definition of high
median it's because if it's just me
wanting honesty I guess so [ __ ] also
man I can't behind man is I grew up poor
yeah I bear ate I've been beaten and
mistreated pushed out of a moving car so
excuse me sweet you know like I may be a
little high-maintenance you should open
the door for my mother when I washing me
know you know so I feel like yeah I have
I can't be high maintenance to some
people because I love the guys are like
oh I like the girls my ex girl was so
cool she would just hang around the do's
and whatever yeah she was just allow
whatever because she didn't feel good
about yeah exactly that's the other
thing you're dating someone who has low
self-esteem
yeah she's not I maintenance
quote-unquote whatever that is for you
that's what I think all right final
question would you date a Republican
what if the dick was really good well
you got a Dana why can't you just smash
everyone that's gonna say what if the
dick like if we yeah I don't know about
dating but I would if I didn't know he
was a Republican and then we [ __ ] and
the dick was good I might [ __ ] him again
but I don't know I wouldn't like date a
Republican not right now I would get a
forever are you making an assumption
that that Republican kettle for Massa no
no of course the Republicans kind of
different now the face of the Republican
you know I was uh I was uh well it's a
friend of mine who she swings from dick
to dick and she I remember when she was
about to be proposed to and I was like
cuz this guy like owned his own business
and all this [ __ ] and he was trying to
get her to move to where whatever state
he was in and she was and this is years
ago like this is maybe even know it was
like Obama era I go is he a Republican
she goes I don't know and I was like
[ __ ] you need to ask him if he's a
Republican because then your whole life
will change and your children will be
raised Republican and conservative and
she had never she had never asked him
she never asked any of the guys in her
that she's dated what their background
was and I was like see that's where the
real issues start with couples and also
where the change and influence comes
into women's lives and I think it's like
you got to [ __ ] ask these I mean now
especially now but
back then I was like that's [ __ ]
crazy that you don't know yeah how long
was she dating they were together for a
while I mean he was about to propose
like Wow yeah
there's levels now there are people
they'll say I'm a Republican but I
didn't vote for Trump yeah yeah like
there's a whole bunch of yeah I'm just
fiscally conservative you're so
Republican [ __ ] well I mean if you're a
fiscally conservative you're your fiscal
conservatism it comes at the price of
the people at the bottom who are trying
to survive so even if you're a fiscally
conservative you're still participating
in the oppression of this yeah so so yes
I would [ __ ] a dick if I didn't know he
was conservative do those guys and
that's you welcome everybody back thank
you for coming and being here ladies
thank you so much catch us next time
peace
[Music]